while teaching is very much aligned with
my life's mission I find that a lot of
my downtime is spent that are sort of
recovering and resting and I seem I feel
quite depleted at the end of the week
I'm wondering if you can speak to
locations and because I'm thinking like
I feel that maybe in New York City is
not the right place for me how did you
decide on Montana and LA my other
question is I find that I keep
simplifying more and more and I wonder
does it become clear when you finally
reached enough or at some point do you
just say this is good because I find
that as I keep going deeper on this
journey I keep realizing I'll actually
need less stuff and it just feels like
maybe I've become a little bit obsessed
and my time is but too much sort of
finding good places to simplify so right
she's a middle school teacher and she
talked about how that aligns with her
life's mission I think that
differentiation the the word she used
whether it's intentional or not she said
it aligns with her life's mission but
she didn't say it was her life's mission
and I think that's that's a good she's
recognizing something that she has a
life submission maybe that's to
contribute maybe that's to help kids but
there are different ways to do that and
maybe just maybe it has nothing to do
with the location that she's in she's in
New York City yeah and but she's also it
sounds to me like an introvert like I am
I think it's perfectly okay it's fine to
be an introvert in the city although
it's just well I find a lot of
introverts prefer to be in crowded
cities yeah I wonder like for you who is
you know high introvert what is it about
a tight tightly packed city that makes
you feel like you can still be
introverted well right yeah well and why
is it appealing I guess it's appealing
to me because well it's what I call
ambient people having access to people
and and and so the ability to connect
although
there's another type of introvert and
they tend to be older men living in
Montana or Alaska were like literally
they'll live by themselves and not see
people for weeks at a time
they wouldn't yeah they would never live
in LA or New Yorker right right exactly
and they don't even want the potential
for interaction in fact that's what sort
of turns them away from cities is they
don't want that potentially I want to be
bothered and well I don't necessarily
want to be bothered either I think I
have the right to be left alone I want I
want the ability to be able to to
connect with other people if need be and
that's one I've been one of the great
things about living in Los Angeles for
me is we have met so many new people
where I have access to them I don't have
to see them every single day but if I
have a friend who I have coffee with
once a quarter then that's great I have
that access a lot of people come through
here too which is really cool yeah yeah
is that that's a that's a great point
because you're living somewhere where
you have access to other people when
they come through here not a lot of
people were coming through Missoula
Montana when we lived there yeah I mean
occasionally and then of course we would
like spend time with them but it's so
weird I would always offer people to
come out to Missoula Montana which for
me like that's like if I was given the
option to go to Montana and had a place
to stay in the mountains like I would do
everything I could yeah to get out there
cuz I mean it is just like that's that's
my paradise you know yeah not many
people took me up on that offer right
but when I threw that offer in LA mm-hmm
dude it's funny cuz like within the
first two or three months I had to like
scale it back and be like oh like like
everyone's now taking me up on this
offer to stay at my place yeah you I'm
rescinding the offer but I think of a
lot of it has to do with like people do
just I mean Ellie's a hub so people come
here often Missoula is a is a
destination it's not really a hub of
sorts and in California but but Southern
California and an LA especially I mean
it's a world city right and so there's
something like 12 million people in the
county 20 million people and them in the
metro area so you can also find people
who align with what your preferences and
hobbies and everything I mean you've met
friends who you go surfing with now yeah
I don't have those same friends because
I don't I don't go surfing it's not that
I have
judgment against that person but like
it's it's in fact a good friend of mine
Andre you know Andre he went to a comedy
store with us yes ago he's like hey do
you and Becks want to go out with me and
and and my girl for you know like a
board game night and I'm like no of
course I don't want to like miserable
right but but it's also being honest
about what my preferences are and that's
I think where we are with Sarah right
now is she has been on she's starting to
be honest with herself about what her
preferences are I remember being in the
corporate world to make this analogous
to what she to her professional career
when I was in the corporate world I had
I had to be an extrovert almost all day
right
managing people leading teams of people
interacting with customers no matter
what my role was even when I was just a
sort of front line salesman in a retail
store all the way up to being a director
of a bunch of retail stores
I had to interact with people 24 hours a
day now part of that aligned with the
person I wanted to because I did want to
lead people I wanted to help people I
wanted to add value to people's lives
and maybe 20% of what I was doing
allowed me to do that but the other 80%
did not actually align with the person I
wanted to become and I think that's
where maybe Sarah is right now she it's
I don't know that it's the city it could
be the city and the only way you'll know
is to try out a different city doesn't
mean you do it for a long period of time
I just had our friend Nate Nate green is
moving I mean he he did that breakup
podcast with him 1:48 yeah and now he's
he's been living in Montana for you know
a while and that there in Portland he's
like trying to figure out like what's
his next step and so he and I did a
living room conversation together on
YouTube shout-out to YouTube audience
hey you know and when we were on living
room conversations he's testing
something out for the next year he's
gonna he's moving to he's moving
somewhere overseas in Asia and then I
he's going to Thailand right yeah but a
specific part where there's a he's doing
he's doing some sort of meditation and
yeah
to a particularly amusing man and then
he's he's probably gonna go to Croatia
for six months after that
and and then after that he's not really
sure where he's going to be and I think
that's the nice thing so Sara asked how
did you choose Montana how did you
choose Los Angeles yeah it was it's
funny man when we went on that tour our
very first tour was what 2011 yeah at
the end of the year and we did basically
you know 75 the highway 75 we went down
to Florida and then we you know
Tennessee stuff that you and I have seen
a million times then we started to
branch out and go to like Chicago or
Phoenix or Portland or LA and I just
remember having that feeling that you
were talking about earlier before we got
in these questions about how you just
want to run from Dayton Ohio because
well I think when you're raised
somewhere everything gets a little bit I
don't wanna say boring but you would you
want a change of scenery
yeah and Dayton Ohio you know the it is
a beautiful place don't get me wrong but
yeah I was like all right no more
cornfields you know no more allergies I
want to like get out and see some
awesome scenery or like being a cool
city right and every city we went to
mana which is like Oh Portland's awesome
let's move to Portland you remember me
like constantly say every place no do we
should move to San Francisco in fact I
was looking at at and this was back in
what 2012 I was looking or 22 2011 2012
I was looking at places to live in San
Francisco so I was like okay that sounds
good and I started looking and it's like
$4,000 for a studio apartment and that
was back then it's even worse now yeah
we just did Kevin roses show and that's
one of the reasons he left San Francisco
is like the crazy skyrocketing prices of
everything and that's something else you
have to keep in mind she lives in
Brooklyn right now imagine how the cost
of living in New York City or were in LA
the cost of living here I was just
having this conversation with our friend
Amy from from Google or formerly from
from Google if you went to go work for a
non-profit but and one of the things you
have to keep in mind that the reason
that la is a hard city to live in is
because the cost of living is
astronomical yeah the the article I just
saw Richard Florida I believe did this
study and Sean if I could find this I'll
send it to you when we could put it in
the show notes but Richard Florida did
the study of how much it cost for an
apartment in Soho in Manhattan
you could buy over a hundred houses in
Toledo or Dayton it's unbelievable the
average house in in Soho yeah the
average a person equals over a hundred
home average cost of wow that's
unbelievable homes that is humble yeah
yeah yeah I think you could do 70 in in
Detroit and 100 and Youngstown I mean it
what was fascinating is cost of living
has to be a has to play a major factor
and that was one of the the things that
allowed me to and we're gonna talk about
this I think with Javier's question
coming up next but but the cost of
living in Dayton allowed me to pay off
my debt it would've been much harder in
a city like Los Angeles for me to become
completely debt-free because I didn't by
definition I'm gonna spend more money on
on just my bare essentials alright keep
it a roof over your head keep yourself
fed the average house in Los Angeles not
not just the nice places like Silver
Lake or Los Feliz or West Hollywood or
Venice the average house in all of LA is
approaching $600,000 in god it's
unbelievable and and you know you go to
a place I date and you can get a nice
house for $60,000 now $100,000 and date
and we'll get you a mansion you know be
the the Beverly Hills equivalent times
two you've brought by to Beverly Hills
houses and in Dayton that's so crazy you
know it's funny like as we're talking
about this I'm asking myself like why do
we move to LA again but you know
honestly man like because of the podcast
and the projects that we're working on
like this really is the place to be
right now for us right some few words
right now yeah right now and you know I
look at it like an investment the the
cost of living it is yes way higher than
most places in the US but I don't look
at it as like a waste of money I don't
look at it as like
anything other than an investment that
that Mariah and I not just with our
money but our time too so you know just
to Sara's point like she's got a look at
you know when she moves to another place
is it yeah if she needs to save some
money great but saving money isn't
always the the right reason to pick a
place or not right although I wouldn't
have moved to LA if we were in debt no
and and because it would be more
difficult to pay off that debt yeah so
let's talk real quick about so you sort
of illuminate a why we moved to LA it's
a place where people go to tell stories
you wanna talk about Montana first well
we moved to Montana yeah yeah that's
that I think that's a better starting
point so we're in Dayton Ohio we did
this 33 City tour with our first book
minimalism live a meaningful life I
wanted to move to every single city we
went to all 33 cities
32 others it was Dayton and 32 other
things but yeah every time we're there I
mean I remember being in Knoxville yeah
it was great Knoxville right and and
what I started to realize is oh I can be
happy anywhere oh yeah it's we don't
hate change we hate being changed but
when we implement change on our own we
actually look forward to that right and
that's what I looking at those cities
now if someone were to tell you Ryan if
all of a sudden you have been told hey
you have to move to Knoxville you be
like what why and be like no but I
wouldn't like to be forced to move
anywhere exactly and so what we like is
our ability to have control over our own
change where people say I hate change I
think they're wrong because if their
bank account changes seven figures and
the positive all of a sudden they're
gonna be like yeah I like that chain
right well what we mean is we hate being
change we hate unexpected change we hate
changes that are thrust upon us so
Sarah's in a good position right now
because she's looking for elsewhere so
if she decides to stay in Brooklyn then
she can make that decision on her own so
what why did we move out to Montana man
um Missoula what yeah yeah so god man I
don't know where to start I mean I guess
how about this we were dry we were the
very end of the tour the thirty-third
city was Vancouver BC yeah we were
finishing it up driving through Montana
and before we got to Montana was it was
late and we were like you know we were
in Idaho we're like you know what we're
just gonna stop here in Idaho yeah
spend the night and then we're gonna get
up tomorrow and just like barrel through
Montana and get it and get it over with
we'd never been to Montana never never
never never even thought about Montana
yeah and then and then we stopped in
Coeur d'Alene Idaho and they'd you know
one of the charges like 250 bucks a
night for a hotel room
which was crazy I was like we're in the
Panhandle I know we're a little no way
I'm like dude there's no one in your
parking lot right now look I don't
understand he did lower it like I think
he you know was like 200 bucks or
something yeah um but yeah he was saying
he was just telling me he's like dude
he's like there's a really nice place
he's like uh you know basically trying
to explain to me why I was so expensive
well when we woke up in the morning and
saw the beauty of Coeur d'Alene it was
like oh like this is why that's 200
bucks a night because it's like a very
very gorgeous one of the most gorgeous
places that I've been to in this country
honestly and then we started driving
into Montana that morning yeah and it
was just I don't want to say it was more
beautiful or less as much as it was just
different Beauty around every corner for
me it literally was more beautiful I we
were in Idaho and as soon as you cross
that line in the Montana for some reason
it's like it's picturesque yeah and then
we hit that spot there's this tiny
little waterfall right off of i9 well
before that we stopped to get coffee in
Missoula and Missoula Montana and what
was crazy about Missoula was a we found
awesome coffee and we found awesome fish
tacos and like rest so those are two
things that when we go to a city that's
what we kind of consider is like how
good is the food yeah can you get some
decent food and you know not like
sit-down restaurant food but just like
they didn't have a triple Laila I mean
that's I mean they have one now but when
we first moved there they didn't have a
Chipotle that was almost a game breaker
or a you know game changer except they
had good fish tacos it's like all right
all right we can do fish tacos instead
of your poll eh
yeah and then I remember just going to
oh no is it La Petite yeah yeah La
Petite I was like I forget the name of
the plate late with the labor bleep yeah
we went to Lake petit Missoula Montana
which by the way awesome bakery awesome
coffee if you're in Missoula Montana
definitely got a lot late petit but I
heard number the barista waiting on us
and you know cuz like I have this like
this inner hippie in me I just remember
like seeing the people working there and
like a they were so nice dude like
that's the one thing about Montana about
Missoula is that people don't look at me
like I'm weird like when I go up to
someone hey how's it going like they
give me the same energy back yeah
there's no like they there's not a
people don't have a lot of a lot of
walls up and in Missoula I feel like
yeah um you go up to someone in Dayton
Ohio or Los Angeles hey I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and they're gonna look at you
like all right dude
okay what do you want what's up like you
know like they'd be a little bit
trepidatious we're in Missoula you go up
to someone hey I'm Ryan Nicodemus
they're like okay you're cool until you
prove me otherwise right so I so like I
loved that feeling but then also dude I
remember thinking to myself I could
probably find a drum circle here now I
never was in a drum circle actually
that's not true
Mariah's mom they do a couple drum
circles a year and I was like there was
one of them that I was in it was kind of
fun but but I you know for all intents
and purposes like I that was the only
drum circle was ever in in five years so
we left we we left lay petit we got our
coffee we hit the road again we're on
i-90 and and then all of a sudden
there's this little waterfall off the
side of off the side of the highway and
it looked like someone was filming an
Abercrombie and Fitch ad it was like
dudes with raging six-packs like chicks
and thongs it wasn't it was
skinny-dipping right and so like there
were six college kids for women two men
and they were jumping into this little
sort of hot spring waterfall thing on
the side of the highway it's the first
time my life I've ever done a triple
take and as I looked over and this is
not made up a bald eagle flew overhead
and the only thing more American is they
would have been like waving some sort of
American flag or the eagle had it in his
talons or something and and what I
realized like oh like this is what
advertisements try to affect is what's
going on right here in Montana today now
granted it was it was mid-july early
July of 2012 and which by the way is the
absolute perfect time oh yeah we got so
lucky when we were passing through
there's two solid months of weather
sometimes only
one solid month of weather a year in
Montana and in Missoula specifically and
and it was like the perfect time so
gorgeous weather 85 degrees
skinny-dipping beautiful college kids
I've never seen a bald eagle in my life
I'm from Dayton Ohio we don't have many
bald eagles there unless they're on the
currency or in a zoo right and so we
sort of looked at each other and you're
like hey we should come back out here to
write the next book yeah so for me it
was the community
it was access to the the basic
preferences that I had yes good coffee
good fish tacos good pizza although I
don't meats anymore I miss pizza
especially the pineapple on it so anyway
what's different about Missoula I mean
you can get those things pretty much
anywhere you go to Saskatoon and find
good coffee and and good people yeah
yeah so what I was getting to is uh just
the community in general that's what
really drew me to Missoula not only that
but sweeping mountains awesome views and
then you know kind of totally
romanticizing this writer in a cabin
yeah side of a mountain which is what we
did for months we first moved out there
was October 3rd 2012 I remember I
arrived there a week before you did and
the day I got there was snowing and I
don't mean over yeah early October do
Mariah and I left for LA in September
and we drove here it was snowing on the
way it was like the last snow anyway it
was like Blizzard et I mean and so
getting there I'm like oh this is
different from what I remember back in
July and so we rented this cabin in the
middle of nowhere from Craigslist and we
just wrote and and and spent those four
months creating our book everything that
remains but then we found ourselves
gravitating toward Missoula which was
two hours away mm-hmm
we lived in this little you know it was
Phillipsburg Montana there's one traffic
light in in 3,400 square miles but if
you really wanted to go to a city you
either went to Butte or you went to
Missoula when we found ourselves
gravitating toward Missoula and so the
end of that we decided hey let's
actually move to this city there's
70,000 people there it's it's not a
massive city but it feels
much more like the city because it's
dense because it's built in between
those mountain ranges yeah Colin also
wanted to live with us too
yeah so this is kind of what spawned us
really making this move Colin was like
man let's get together live together for
six months let's see what kind of
creations we can make and you know we it
was time for us to graduate from from
that small little town yeah so we went
into it only planning to be in that
cabin for four months and let's see
let's see what's gonna happen we didn't
have a well let's move here for the rest
of our lives and I think that's quite
often the mentality we get into I and we
we get we it becomes much more difficult
to make a decision if the decision is I
have to make this decision and stick
with it for the rest of my life it's way
easier when you're like hey I'm gonna
give myself four months here because you
can do four months anywhere right and
yes Colin wanted to come out because we
were starting a publishing house
together asymmetrical press and so we
set up shop together the three of us in
Missoula Montana yeah and then we ended
up both meeting the loves of our lives
and in Montana and sticking around there
for about five years as a result I will
say this though you and I differ on
Missoula because for me I didn't find my
community there yeah and it was really
difficult I remember being like oh I
still feel this attachment to Dayton
because that was where my community was
and I was unable to find the the right
people for me in Missoula so um I guess
see I talked about what is uh what is
community to you meaning so for me when
I say community it's like I Missoula
Montana I feel like the only place I
could ever live and accidentally fall in
to the main role of a play I mean I was
at a game night yeah and next thing I
know I'm like you know got the lead role
in this in this play and then I was able
to make some friends from there so for
me it's I guess is acceptance really
it's like a community that I agree with
that
so I never felt accepted in Missoula by
and large yeah there's obvious
differences let me I met Becks out there
yeah obviously I felt accepted by her
but and and by you and by a few other
people whom I met you know our friend
Nate green we
we met in in Missoula Montana so there
were there was a handful of people but
it was nice why agree with you
acceptance as part of it I think
preferences or another part of it
desires having similar desires as people
in the community and so I didn't there
weren't a lot of type threes you know
the Enneagram type three and achievers
and Missoula Montana oh I may be I don't
agree with that the reason why I say
that that was because one thing about
community for me too is how involved are
people in the community how well do they
treat their community and Missoula is
tight-knit not only that there are some
very very famous people producers
directors writers you know old tell
adage it like there's a ton of talent in
Missoula well there aren't a ton of
people there I think is the and so like
it was more difficult because I'm an
introvert and I spend way less time you
know you and I talked about the three
the three concentric circles of
relationship give your primary
relationships which are like the five
people were close to your immediate
family loved ones the the second layer
your secondary relationship so you're
your good friends and extended family
and the third layer you're sort of you
you can either called acquaintances or
you can call the the people on the
periphery as an introvert I have far
more people in that third tier on the
periphery yeah Ben C then you do you
have way more people on the the second
tier than I do
yeah like I've got I've got a list of
people who I never really got to develop
relationships with the Missoula and I
remember thinking like well not even
think it had happened where when I moved
to Missoula I you know had it's called
five people that it was really close to
one would move away and then I was like
oh yes that means I could bring someone
else in that I really wanted to get to
know right and like I that list is still
pretty long yeah I mean so I would say
you know if Dunbar's number is 150 you
probably have a hundred people in that
second tier I have a hundred people 130
140 people in the Third's here whereas I
have very few secondary relationships
you're either really close to me or I
can so call you a friend then we can
hang out once or twice a year but that's
that that's pretty much it for me i
prioritize my time alone first but when
I did want to spend time with people I
just didn't have
community of people in Missoula it
doesn't mean they're wrong or I'm wrong
I just there wasn't it was a puzzle
piece that didn't fit yeah the one thing
that you said that stands out to me is
his preferences yes and like that's I
think that's what it comes down to
because you know going back to that
introvert who lives in a cabin in the
middle of nowhere in Alaska who would
never live in New York vice versa like
someone in New York may never ever want
to go out and live in that cabin in the
middle of nowhere it all comes down to
preferences yes absolutely does so so I
think when we're talking to when we're
talking to Sarah here she had two
questions one is about the location she
feels drained I don't think it's the
location that's draining her necessarily
it might be but I think it's her
profession that is draining her and and
it might mean that you have to figure
out what your mission is what's the
actual mission and then how do you
fulfill that based on your preferences
or your personality and it might mean
that you're helping children by writing
textbooks or children's books yeah and
that you you're spending most of your
time alone in doing that or it might
mean that you have to find a way to
mentor students one-on-one because as
someone like me I'm much better
one-on-one whenever we go out as a group
like it's really difficult for me like I
get overwhelmed but if we just have a
sit-down one-on-one in fact Becks
noticed us the other day meet you and
Mariah and Becks all went out to dinner
right in four of us
yes went over to Takaya yes and after
our backs goes you and Ryan are the only
two people I know who can just talk
together forever
and it's because I have a guy I mean I
can't even do that with backs the way
that I do it with you it's cuz we know
we've just known each other for so long
exactly and we know what the other
person is going to say before they say
it quite often yeah and we come back we
have callbacks and little inside jokes
that are only funny to us but we think
they're really funny yeah yeah we swear
were the most hilarious people on earth
but how many times you gotta talk about
it doing a joke like with the podcast
something and you're like dude there's
only two people who would find that joke
funny it's so hyper specific yeah and
and so lay you're like hey what about
mrs. cordini and I'm like they're not
gonna get that on the body
anyway shout-out to miss Cordy
yeah and so so when I what I learned
about you and I is like I'm so much
better well even when like the four of
us were together it was sort of like you
and I siphoned ourselves off and we just
had a conversation because it's so much
easier for me to do that you do just as
well or maybe even better amongst a
group of people especially people you
don't know what for me like I would just
like I want to leave immediately yeah so
I've been getting back to Sarah here
though she did sound I mean to me she
sounded not that she should really liked
her profession but that she was excited
about her profession mm-hmm and you know
it's funny you were saying maybe it's a
profession of the city when I think
about living in New York City it's I get
drained just thinking about I agree I
agree with that
New York seems overwhelming to me and
most like a lot of people who I talked
to who live in New York the biggest
complaint that I hear is how much you
have to work in order to afford to live
there so that could be a piece of it for
for Sarah here well that's the having to
versus what getting to right yeah so
it's like the change thing where it's
like you may want a change and you then
you accept it but if you're forced into
working overtime just to pay the rent
yeah roach-infested well Joe York apart
perfect example is you know we would
work you know 50 60 70 80 hour work
weeks yeah we there are some weeks where
we will work 50 60 70 80 hour work weeks
uh-huh it's definitely far and few
between you're saying that then versus
now
yeah I'm sorry yeah then versus now so
like now it's like we choose to do it
right late you're absolutely right like
if you were to tell me all right Ryan
all right dude like in order to make
this work we have to work 80 hours a
week from now on I would be like dude
like we have to reconsider but you know
if we are on tour uh-huh you know I mean
when we're on tour I mean we're pretty
much working all you know all day we get
to sleep at night yeah and you know 75%
of the nights we get you know eight
hours a chance to sleep eight hours but
25% we don't right but it is much
different like choosing to do that
rather than like you know yeah just like
having that
being forced into well being being in
control is is part of it and right now I
sound to me like what Sarah is dealing
with she feels like she's not in control
that's why she feels depleted so there
there's a good kind of tired and a bad
kind of tired right you go to the gym
and you work out really hard nicodemus
lifts all the weights all of them and
then after I got to bring weights in
from the back afterward though you feel
like a good kind of tired you you feel
exhausted but in a good way
yeah now she feels depleted in a bad way
yeah and where she doesn't feel like she
has the adequate time for recharging now
if you leave the gym you're like I'm
exhausted I'm gonna come back in 40
minutes well all of a sudden be like
then that doesn't feel good you're gonna
feel depleted but when you come back
forty minutes later like I have to lift
these weights again and so there's also
that time for recovery and that's why I
suspect she's an introvert I feel like
she's not getting enough time alone to
recharge on her own and then that leads
into her second question she says well
then I I feel like I'm oversimplifying
right I mean it do I ever get there do I
ever get to this minimalist life
you